всім привіт з вами авраам лінкольн
вірніше він зі мною
мені це добре а я drill та ганський ми
поговоримо сьогодні разом із авраамом
лінкольному з вами про важливий авраам
лінкольн красень і взагалі молодець він
людина, яка сама собі зробила це
селфі адмін почитайте його біографії
почитайте обов'язково його висловлювання
оскільки цими висловлюваннями ви
користуєтеся постійно, але в основному ви
не знаєте авторство і це сказав не
черчіль ви цього черчілля можете
побачити скрізь і всюди з кожної праски
воду у ванній відкриваєш звідти цитата
черчілля щодо наших сьогоднішніх
реалій авраам лінкольн
говорив наступне, що можна обманювати
частини народу весь час можна дурити
весь народ
деякий час але не можна обманювати
постійно так і вийшло так і вийшло
результаті виборів після виборів на
сьогоднішній день провели соцопитування центр
розумкова разом із записав собі з
представництвом фонду конраду
аденауера а це дуже важливо, оскільки
це під контролем німців з німецькою
точністю та підтверджуючи вибірку
статистику підтверджуємо методи
проведення запиту і так далі це дуже
важливо для Європи перевірити сьогоднішні
політичні симпатії України вже після
виборів не перед виборами до місцевих
вибори пройшли, а після виборів це теж
дуже важливо зрозуміти
чи поділяють українці рейтинги партій на
місцевих виборах та на парламентських до
поділяють українці не дурні, щоб вам
хто не говорив українці розуміють що
коли ви голосуєте за місцеву партію
наприклад я не знаю у вінниці за
гройсмана
гройсман гройсман то це означає що
люди які живуть вінниці довіряють цим
людям питання розподілу місцевого
бюджету доріг лікарень садків та шкіл
державні справи державного
масштабу їм не довіряють тому в цих
рейтингах ви не побачите цих містечкових
місцевих партій та й не побачите пальців
кого що дивно судячи з кількості
бігбордів або білбордів як правильно по
всій країні пальчевський мав
перемогти в цих виборах але немає народу
україни на таких вже елементарних
маніпуляціях не проведеш і так що ж
показали нам рейтингу рейки показали нам
наступне український народ розуміється на
політиці просто пробиває а й днище
падає з величезною швидкістю до вниз як
літак який просто йде в піку у
якого відмовили всі двигуни його
притягує до землі логіка розбивається
рейтинг партії слуга народу
чому тому що немає такої партії слуга
народу тому що це політичний
проект тому що це обман обман майже
всього народу на деякий час
зелінський його команда коломойський ось
це вся медіа
сфера яка працювала на них і обдурили
майже весь народ України, але на деяке
час
обманювати весь народ України не
вийде постійно лінкольн вам про це
говорив давним-давно частину народу дар
частина народу на сьогодні досі
обманута обіцянками закінчити війну
знизити тарифи війна не закінчилася
тарифи зросли
зелений обіцяв знизити тарифи
ось його обіцянки а тарифи зросли ось
інформація про зростання тарифів
це обман
проте на першому місці якби
парламентські вибори відбулися у цьому
неділя на першому місці досі
партія слуга народу
але там не переважна більшість а
лише 28 відсотків двадцять вісім
відсотків
порівняйте і слідом же йде опозиційна
партія головна опозиційна партія на
сьогоднішній день з конструктивною
порядком денним який змагається зі
слугою народу власне у процесі
входження у владу опозиція завжди
хоче стати владою в цьому полягає
сенс політичних взагалі рухів та
політичної діяльності партія
європейська солідарність набрала просто
просто багато відсотків і велике
кількість виборців у тому числі
завдяки вам глядачі завдяки тим хто
включає якісь якісь
розумові процеси
причинно-наслідкові зв'язки не піддається
обману 21 відсоток це добрий результат
повірте це класний шикарний класний
результат на сьогоднішній день 21 відсоток
далі опозиція
опозиційної партії, але вона опозиційно
до України вона не має жодного
ставлення до позиції влади до влади
є вони не опозиційних зеленому рику
чинна влада або попередніх
наприклад каденціях коли порошенка була
президентом і був при владі вони не були
опозиціонерами до порошенка не
опозиціонери
до самої України і так на жаль таких
виборців теж багато шістнадцять з
половиною відсотків віддали б свої
голоси за це ось уже pvp у парку
окупаційні блоки я називаю партія
Батьківщина вісім відсотків хто ці
люди але вони є як би серед нас але я
завжди займався пошуком до задавався
питанням де ви хто ви покажете мені та
де хто був судно голосують вісім
відсотків людей голодують проголосували
б за партії батьківщина хто вони
напишіть у коментарях можливо у вас
є такі знайомі чи родичі
які голосують за партії батьківщина
я їх ну м'яко кажучи не розумію
мені з ними цікаво спілкуватися та
цікаво зрозуміти їх мотивацію напишіть у
коментарях якщо вас такі є сила і
честь п'ять відсотків там мені здається все
ще гірше було свободу 4 відсотки
стабільно свої свободи перебувають у
рамках своїх окреслених нею самою до
жаль для багатьох на жаль для
членів рядових членів партії, окреслених
самої рамок заганяють себе в
маргінальність найчастіше на жаль
нашому але партія з цих чотирьох
відсотків вирости напевно навіть і не
може на жаль
партія свобода 4 відсотка партія голос 3
партія голос навіть луна немає такий шепіт а
вакарчук слава вокарчук який не
згадуйте його та світ sui
ну був такий у нас вакарчук та до речі він
ось там даватиме якийсь концерт
можете сходити
якщо ви за ним скучили сумуєте за
йому будь ласка світильників тобто
партія голос перетворилася на партію шепіт
але це політичний проект який
потихеньку цілком закономірно оскільки
навіть частину народу обманювати нескінченно
теж важко
він зникає і розчиняється хоча хлопці
за україну за європейський шлях за нато
але ж треба мати конструктивну
порядок денний на жаль ну і мій
улюблений пальчевський який напевно
перемагає на виборах можливо у
австралії чи не знаю в антарктиді
якісь
зненацька пінгвіни голосуватимуть за
когось вони проголосують точність
опочецького напевно навіть в антарктиді
можна зустріти ще старенькі до
виборні бігборди цього поліцейського це
політичні проекти, які вже не
злітають україна інша українці до
радості моєї я задоволений цими рейтингу
не тому, що партія європейська коли
рази по 20 поні тому тому що
люди в Україні прогнозовані до вирішення
спробувати до
захотіли халяви популізм це проблема
всього світу сьогодні всього світу в цілому
в тому числі й українці довірили
обіцянкам і обману команди зеленого так
ви казали що це не правда давно
казали що це обман тоді ще на
виборах перед виборами у момент
президентських виборів на парламентських
вибори ми казали що guys це
не-ре-аль-но давайте мислити реально і
конструктивно-конструктивні пропозиції
у партії європейська солідарність була і
тут у нас вийшло переправа у
чотирнадцятому році
виявилося, що російська федерація зовсім
не мирне держави як здавалося
багатьом в Україні
Російська федерація напала на нас
окупувала частину донецька частина
луганській області цілу півострів
окупували і на ось у цей момент
треба було переправитися з одного берега
на інший нам треба було відірватися
економічно ментально культурно нам
треба було відірватися від російської
федерації всіма можливими методами та
силами просто перейти на інший бік
туди на бік добра на бік
демократії свобод розвиненої економіки
бік європейського союзу та блоку НАТО
для безпеки для нашої з вами
безпеки
Європейський Союз дасть нам додаток до
нашій кишені тобто економічна
розвиток нато
дає нам безпеку це було просто але
треба було перейти цю переправу
але як говорив і попереджав завжди і в
його, напевно, теж була якась своя
футболка з написом я ж говорив
лінкольн один колін вас попереджав там
але він казав, що коней на переправі не
змінюють тому вчити історію потрібно
розумних політиків читати потрібно це не
тільки черчілль
розумні політики є і сьогодні, і серед
нас потрібно просто прислухатися
аналізувати робити правильні висновки
але і власне класно, а якщо ми
говоримо про
президентські вибори на сьогодні
рейтинг зеленського 31 відсоток рейтинг
порошенка 21 відсоток що на сьогодні
день цілком можна порівняти і вони природно
виходять у другий тур, тобто переправа
продовжується а нам потрібно з вами думати і
робити правильні висновки босоніж які
вдадуться писати про те, що скільки тобі
платить порошенко чуєш ти порах роботи
так далі за 5 доларів можна підписатися
на patreon луганського посилання на котрий
є в описі та посилання на донатті
є ви і є той самий порошенко
який платить мені зарплату дякую що
ви є до швидких зустрічей поки